at the end of a dirt road outside of Rio
de Janeiro Paulo Sousa is engaging in a
weary daily struggle today we had
nothing to eat I had to go out and ask
her women to help us we had no food
yesterday I cooked some pasta and my
husband asked some fishermen nearby to
give him something from their catch
until three months ago they received
cash from the government the program's
called bolsa família the family bag it
was only about $40 a month but it helped
keep them afloat now for them and about
a million other Brazilians that benefits
been stopped the number of families
newly admitted to the program has also
plummeted to a fraction of those
accepted before it's meant a ballooning
waiting list of half a million people
Salette 58 and unemployed is among them
she says she's been given the runaround
since she tried to join up last August
don't think they they see the
authorities don't care they pushed me
from one place to another like a ping
pong ball
both of familiars help millions of
Brazilians it's the government's
flagship anti-poverty program but it's
been having problems for five years now
and this is just the latest setback it
started when the leftist then government
stopped adjusting payouts to keep up
with inflation now the current
administration has again hit what was a
successful and cheap anti-poverty tool
they are very important and at the same
time it now reaches about what
one-quarter of the of the Brazilian
population the very very poor is very
well targets the money goes to women
goes to children with conditionalities
and cost very little so it costs only
point four percent of the GDP
so you're basically Brazil did as a sort
of fiscal adjustment on the poor for its
recipients not just present survival but
futures and now on hold my children have
baked dreams the eldest wants to join
the army he was training and trying out
for a football club but we had to
withdraw him we couldn't afford his
transport
the government says it's just
reorganizing to improve the program
millions are waiting John Holman
al-jazeera Rio de Janeiro